I think any founder who ultimately plans
to sell something to somebody should be
thinking about their monetization
strategy from day one the reason is not
because the early revenue I think makes
a meaningful difference for your
business from a cash flow perspective
but because acquiring revenue is the
ultimate form of customer validation
it's pretty easy as an entrepreneur to
go out and find somebody to tell you
that you have a cool idea the difficult
part is getting them to open their
wallet and so from that perspective I
see it as a really really great tool in
understanding your customer and
understanding that you've found
something that people want